main review everybody YouTube's most
thought out show hey you see this cat oh
whatever there's a new cat photo out
there meow this is going into my cat
folder compilation finally more funny
pictures of cat that I can share around
and make out a mean side him how could
anyone say no to this cat face huh Bruce
landlord it is clear in the leaves no
pets allowed in this apartment
sumimasen sorry send a photo of the cat
okay I will make an exception because he
looks very perfect this photo was sent
out and he became an immediate cat
sensation it was a cat strophe the see
even true drunk himself thought wow
Sugoi desu nee nico-chan oh also guys i
have a special offer for you guys in
case you aren't aware if you like this
video right now do it you will die
instantly hooray
thanks to this cat what a polite little
kitty how is this a mean your bring you
bring a friend for my home boy is he
cute
is he cute yeah my person cute man so
you see that's where the trouble began I
know you were trouble when you can't in
let's just move on this mean gets a
three I don't know what to tell you it's
another picture of a cat it's clear in
the least no pets allowed in this
apartment Jar Jar Binks ok I will make
an exception he looks very polite and he
is very polite I wonder if you can grab
his eyes you know I kind of want to like
suck his eyes that's not gay it's just
not gay this is literally me when
another cat makes it into cat meme
compilations moving on do not bully
people
do not make fun of anyone what's going
on boys today I'm gonna tell you how to
get a absolutely brand-new will item
from an almost behind next meme is MoMA
next me Takeshi the fastest cloud sound
rapper in the game we have seen his
palette we have seen his strengths and
we have seen how strong he is
but new evidence have a rosin that's the
word
be quiet arisen that shows that he was
actually much listen here come closer
he's much faster you can add it then you
can ever believe what I'm about to show
you is highly classified confidential
government protected footage of
takeshi's 6:9 I know his name is not
Takeshi six 9s there's easier for me to
say I hate when people like
underestimate me like how fast I am a
form video professors
[Music]
6:9 and his girlfriend but who the lady
who the lady holding his girlfriend
captionthis when your last two brain
cells me is that well wiki hekia the
reason why I'm bringing up Takashi what
was six nine again is cuz he was in
trouble guys
that's right I'm starting a GoFundMe
page to save takeshi's bill of a hundred
and fifty thousand bail it's called bail
he got arrested for skipping out on a
court date to face charges that he'd
choke a fan listen he's a great guy
all right so please let's start this
GoFundMe page and see how much we can
race and I swear on my honor as a
youtuber I will donate all the money to
takeshi's bail he needs to get out of
bail if Takeshi doesn't get out of bail
I don't know what I'll do what other
rappers scream extremely loud during
their song I don't know why I'm aiming
theirs so hard I actually like him it
seems like everyone hates him he's just
he's like a little can I say can I say
he's like I mean it as an endearing way
he's a cute little that's not bad that's
not a bad word please it's a wonderful
word for a wonderful person
the alien is back the dama to casita out
of the casita the cousin of casita is
back I don't believe it either because
it's such a bad me why why did this one
have to come back at all means that can
come back and make a rebound this is no
one asked for this who asked for this
who wanted this one duper come back
I didn't hey you know we'll make a great
mean this metal looking alien dancing
imagine having sleep paralysis and
seeing this at the foot of the bed just
again breaking it down and you can't do
anything about it like you hear the
music in the bag and everything now I
want sleep paralysis oh there it is my
god I am terrified right now
it went from funny cute to savage heart
and then anything
[Music]
this metal alien is very everywhere
first time I laugh at this stupid meme
which is one more time than anyone ever
will
[Laughter]
imagine having sleep paralysis and
seeing PewDiePie at the foot of the bed
just breaking it down and you can't do
anything about it like you hear the
music in the back and everything what
you get a 1 like what is this who is
here before PewDiePie meme reviews it I
already had it in the Dom into casita Oh
Oh what is this Oh what is that cool
over a month ago
interesting come on fellow meme stirs hi
I know you're watching this game steams
streaming oh my
[Music]
the mean seems he nobody got time for
that the meme scenes success Xfinity
presents the meme steam their names Dean
is crazy you're so fat hey nobody got
time for them
sorry xfinity where do I sign them
finally a company that gets it it's like
I love me so much like I'm a meme would
I would I would actually consider myself
a mean man
okay finally like I can pay money to
this company
I love the mean scenes they're just like
honestly they're better than these
goddamn dancing alien at least oh my god
what is the last one is it are they
going to confirm the alien dancing guys
[Music]
the Nostalgia having this soundtrack I
love this mean it's so good great
editing great power it makes me feel
good it makes me feel great and lifts me
up see your body is 70% water and daddys
thirst someone made this I mean I'm not
one to talk I'm sure there's some pretty
bad - out there dude I love it it's
coming home it's coming home is it as
soon as Sweden lost against England
people just couldn't stop tweeting at me
oh you won against Sweden you know that
means nothing right oh it's coming up AM
everybody oh it's coming over it's gonna
be so great chaos I uh I hate that guy
mocking me on Twitter disgusting even
trying to threaten my own show meme
review he changed he changed the title
it was meme reviewing the type he know
as soon as England lot this was called H
coming home meme review how dare he try
to steal my show and then England lost
and boom meme review deleted suddenly
the meme isn't so funny now isn't it
because this England is coming home it's
not coming home it's going home and
please stay there England I mean I'm in
England right now what doesn't matter
shut up this video is really funny now
after England lost
it's not your you're going home like
everyone else no one likes you
no one likes Sweden either I don't know
why I have nothing to boast about you
know what I like to do the most in the
whole world I like to grab a monster
energy drink not sponsor I like to crack
that open fire up my playstation 4 Pro
and I like to hold it like this and the
first the first set the saliva in my
mouth is already and then I fire up
World of Tanks and I'm ready and then
that's how I know I'm living if you're
not sipping on a monster drink then you
ain't living Center
that's right I'm almost 30 years old and
I review memes what can I say we're a
classful bunch of people that likes to
sip on a drink a drink that doesn't does
just doesn't represent capitalism it
represents what the world could be while
you kids you have your Takashi 6-9 we
are sipping our way when our Monster
energy drinks and I feel bad you know
whenever I see someone that isn't
sipping on a monster energy drink it
upsets me because I have so much empathy
in my heart and in my soul like if you
ain't zipping you ain't livin it really
doesn't taste get all the memes were
garbage this week well do you think
that's my fault
I'm just reviewing them meme review
leave a like if you enjoyed this video
guys appreciate all the support and
namaste thank you guys and as always